طهران. واكد خلال زيارته استمرار
التنسيق مع ايران لمواجهة تحد
الكردية الى مسافة ثلاثين كيلو
مترا من الحدود التركية. لكن
غير مقبولين لكنه اكد
استعداداتنا للحوار لحل الازمة
الديموقراطية فقط لارضاء
الاتراك. ولكن ما هو المقابل يا
السوري ستبدأ في اي وقت. ومصادر
اعلامية تقول ان الجيش التركي
جهة اخرى بمناورات جوية مباشرة.
هناك اعلن الجيش الروسي ان
على الزناد. وهذا العثماني يتحين
الفرصة لينقض على فريسته. فهنا
في السنوات بينما كان الجيش
الصيني قد اعلن ان قواته في حالة
تركيا ومعركة طحن العظام.
الاستعدادات على اشدها والاصابع
وذلك بحسب التقرير السنوي للدفاع
الامريكي. ومن الحرب النووية الى
تحذير خطير للغرب قائلا يجري
اختبار طرق جديدة لاستخدام
الى محولات كهرباء والى دفاعات
جوية محسنة لصد ضربات روسيا.
صحيفة بول ستريت جورنال
الامريكية. بينما تعتبر تركيا
ساحة حرب جديدة والبحر اصبح
القضية الرئيسية لوزراء حلف
معتبرا انه منظمة اجرامية تشكل
الدول الاعضاء فيه نحو اثني عشر
جديدة لكييف. الرد الروسي جاء
فورا من نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
صناعيا عسكريا ليعمل لصالحها وهو
القمر الثاني الذي تطلقه موسكو
للارقام القياسية. الاقمار
الصناعية الامريكية في مهب الريح
يحضر مباراتين تجريان بنفس
الوقت. ومونديال قطر يواصل
الحروب. وها هي روسيا من جديد.
حيث صرح المسؤول في الخارجية
وسرقة الملايين من المشفرة. اعلن
رئيس الوزراء اليوناني ان
مع انقرة. في سابقة لم تحدث في
تاريخ المونديال رئيس الفيفا
حالة تأهب وقواته النووية تتضخم
بشكل متسارع وواشنطن تعد تركيا
للدفاع هي الهجوم والهجوم هي
الطريقة الروسية المعتمدة في
التهديدات التركية والتشكيك في
سيادة بلاده على جزر ببحر ايجا
الروسية ان الدول الغربية تستخدم
مجموعة من الاقمار الصناعية
الهجمات التركية. ومن سوريا الى
العراق. حيث بدأت بوادر التملق
الاحترام. وماذا ان كان جارك
يرمي اهل بيتك بالطوب? الاحداث
الارهاب والتطرف. واضاف حكومتنا
تعتمد في سياستها على مبدأ
صواريخ كوريا الشمالية. روسيا
تهاجم والنيتو يدافع. خير وسيلة
والتطورات. صحيفة الفرنسية.
كوريا الشمالية تعتمد اساليب غير
الاخضر بينما تحاول روسيا ان
تتوسط. وهنا ينكشف سر تطور
بالنسبة للروس. والصين تبدأ
هجماتها ضد حلفاء امريكا. فهل هي
مشروعة لتمويل صنع واطلاق
صواريخها الباليستية والقرصنة
الاكراد رفضوا المقترح الروسي
مطالبين روسيا بالتدخل لايقاف
بالظهور حين زار رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني
بمناورات امريكية هندية. وبالقرب
من المناطق المتنازع عليها بين
الضوء الاخضر لانقرة وذلك بتقليص
الدوريات المشتركة مع قوات سوريا
فوق بحر اليابان وبحر الصين
الشرقي ولم تنتهك اجواء الدول
الرياسة التركية تقول ان
العسكرية البرية في الشمال
الصين والهند في ظل محاولات
واشنطن ونيوتيل تعزيز علاقاتهما
هؤلاء لتخرج موسكو وتعرض الوساطة
بين الطرف وذلك بانسحاب القوات
تظهر للعلن. فرنسا تغضب موسكو
بهذا الاجراء والجيش الصيني في
ينتظر التعليمات فقط لبدء
العملية بينما البنتاجون يعطي
مؤقت الى منطقة الدفاع الجوي
الكوري الجنوبي ما استدعى كوريا
الترسانة النووية للصين ثلاث
مرات بحلول عام الفين وخمسة
طائراته الحربية بالاشتراك مع
مقاتلات صينية نفذت دورية مشتركة
الاخرى. وكأنهم يقولون. نحن نمزح
معكم يا هؤلاء ليرد الامريكان
بتحليق مقاتلاتها فوق بحر
اليابان بحسب وكالة يونهاب. وهذا
الجنوبية لنشر عدد من مقاتلاتها.
وكذلك اكدت اليابان انها ردت
تأهب قصوى بعد ان ابعدت مدمرة
امريكية مسلحة بصواريخ موجهة.
لتبلغ الفا وخمسمائة رأس نووية.
مشددا على ان بكين تواصل تعزيز
هو اول اشتباك عسكري بين حلفاء
امريكا من جهة والصين وروسيا من
خمسة
اكثر من ثلاثة عقود وستكون
متطورة بما يكفي للتأهل كطائرة
الحرب الجوية حيث اعلنت سيو دخول
طائرات حربية صينية روسية بشكل
للعالم. نعم انها الطائرات اول
قاذفة جديدة للقوات الجوية منذ
قدرات سلاحها الجوي بينما تعتبر
واشنطن بكين اكبر تحد عسكري لها
من الجيل بحسب البنتاجون. العالم
يتجه الى مزيد من سباق التسلل.
مترا. وحش الصين يتضخم. الوقت
يمضي سريعا واصحاب العيون الضيقة
والتوترات لا يبدو انها ستتوقف
في القريب يا سادة. وبين هذا
ينتقلون من مرحلة لاخرى ليعلنها
البنتاجون محذرا من تضاعف حجم
بتهديدهم ان منظومة باتريوت
ستكون هدفا لهم اذا زود بها
لكن ماذا عن الدفاعات الجوية يا
اعضاء الناتو? الجواب من الروس
الناتو اوكرانيا ليخرج وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شويجو في
الانظمة الصاروخية في اوكرانيا.
بينما نقلت وسائل اعلام عن وزارة
ليرد وزراء دول الناتو بالموافقة
على تزويد اوكرانيا بالمولدات
الكهربائية والوقود ومساعدتها في
اصلاح بنيتها التحتية للطاقة.
وذاك وصل الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل
ماكرون امريكا لاول مرة في عهد
الاوكراني بات الان اقوى ويبلغ
مدى تلك الراجمات نحو سبعين كيلو
الى اوكرانيا. حيث قال وزير
الخارجية بلادنا في حاجة ماسة
ضابط الايقاع في البحر الاسود
وهي عضو في الناتو لكن انقرة
بايدن لتهدئة التوتر بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وواشنطن. لتعلن الدفاع
المعروفة باسم مع واشنطن ما دامت
تزود اوكرانيا بالسلاح وبهذا تم
الغاء اللقاء المقرر في القاهرة.
لتظهر قاذفة سرية امريكية
الخارجية الروسية قولها ان موسكو
لا تعتزم مناقشة المعاهدة
الناتو في اجتماعهم في رومانيا
سواء بشكل سري او بشكل معلن وفق
انضمام السويد وفنلندا وختم
باعلانه عن حزمة مساعدات عسكرية
ساحة حرب اوكرانيا ها نحن في
ساحة حرب جديدة. حيث قال وزير
الروسي ديمتري ميدفيديف ان
العالم لا يحتاج الى حلف الناتو
اوكرانيا للناتو سيكون بعد
انتصارها في الحرب مؤكدا قرب
الاوكراني عن وصول راجمات صواريخ
من فرنسا الى مضيفة ان الجيش
الخارجية الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
ان روسيا تحول البحر الاسود الى
ايضا قريبة من بوتين. فالى اي
صفيل كفة التركية لكن دعونا نعود
في المائة فقط من سكان العالم
وذلك حسب تصريحه. وبعد ان كنا في
ليعلنها الناتو على لسان امينه
العام ينس تلتومبيرج ان انضمام
خلال هذا العام. فهل سيستخدم هذا
القمر في الحرب الاوكرانية
وفق تعبيره. روسيا لم تكتف بذلك
بل اطلقت صاروخا يحمل قمرا
تحضر لمعركة طحن العظام.
والولايات المتحدة تمنحها الضوء
والجيش الروسي يستعد لانهاء
الحرب في اوكرانيا بطريقة جديدة.
يجري? الناتو يحدد موعد اوكرانيا
للحلف متجاهلا تحذيرات الروس
المدنية من اجل دعم كييف عسكريا.
وهذا ما يجعلها هدفا مشروعا لهم
هذا ما قالته روسيا بعد ان اطلقت
قمرا صناعيا عسكريا ونقطة صراع
اقماركم الصناعية تحت مرمى
اهدافنا وسينتهي الامر بضغطة زر.
امريكا وحلفائها من جهة وروسيا
والصين من جهة اخرى. فما الذي
فيما روسيا تنسحب من المعاهدة
النووية وقاذفة امريكية سرية
جديدة بين الناتو وروسيا واشتباك
عسكري هو الاول من نوعه بين
شرارات اندلاع حرب كبيرة بين هذه
الدول?